hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well this is a video
designed provided with examples and
applications of moral theory too late'
arianism to help you wrap your head
around how it might be brought into the
everyday world is very important because
Jeremy Bentham thought that the moral
philosophy that he was putting forth of
utilitarianism really did have a lot of
traction for our ordinary everyday life
and then gave me a large respect he's
correct and we're talking about product
design this is one of the areas of the
economy of life in general where we
actually do use the word utilitarian and
it's not always framed in terms of moral
theory of such we see you know why is
just a few minutes but it does have some
traction when we use the term
utilitarian what we're usually thinking
about I think of these these three
factors over here the utilitarian design
is something that's not particularly
attractive that is is done you know for
the sake of other other values right
helpfulness
the way fits into to a given system you
know in some way to be used the term
utilitarian as a substitute for
pragmatic now if you're thinking about
these things in terms of products for
human use in terms until the terriot
isms of all theory remember what is it
these he'll Terry doesn't say what we
want to do is we want to maximize human
pleasure or happiness and minimize your
pain or unhappiness the antic Tillett
Arianism looks at everybody concerned so
it doesn't just look at you the way you
know egoistic perspective on that would
do it is it is much more widespread and
saying everybody's pleasure he counts so
you know think about it for example
lighting on fire crackers on your on
your neighbors step it could be quite
fun to this sort of thing we did as kids
when I was a kid and we got a real kick
out of it we got a lot of pleasure out
of it the more firecrackers we had to
light off you know for us the better it
was but there's you know other people
concerned you know the neighbor has to
clean up their step sometimes it's not
just a matter of sweeping up well
fragments of paper but you know actually
burn marks and things like that that are
hard to get out like scare them which
produces a kind of unhappiness it you
know you could be seeing some longer
lasting effects you'll screw up
friendships if you know if they find out
who it is they got to call your parents
and then you know your parents have some
castles as well so you can see that
actions sometimes you have these wider
debts of consequences and they make
great pleasure for some people and
maximize pleasures or some people but
creating pain for other people so
utilitarian we want to take account of
that and when it comes to designing
products or producing products or
selling products or marketing products
all these sorts of things that we we do
with them a utilitarian would want to be
conscious of those elements as well
we'll talk about some of these issues
about marketing and things like that
when I do a video specifically on
business applications so let's come back
to this why are these important factors
cost reliability durability well you
know if you can produce ten times the
amount of units a given thing let's
let's say we take a luxury item like
cologne and perfume or let's expand this
to any sort of cosmetic products
cosmetic products there's at least for
the more expensive things there is a lot
of money spent on advertising there's a
lot of money spent on promotion in other
respects there are higher quality
ingredients in the more expensive things
but they're not such higher quality
necessarily that it would makes us from
utilitarian perspective that's actually
count them produce them cost is a factor
why is cost effective because every time
you're paying for something you're being
a little bit of pain now you can defer
the payment putting in a credit card or
something like that but in general you
know mean we can measure things in terms
of how much would you be willing to pay
for how much other pleasures are you
willing to forego for it how much hurts
to your you know wallet or pocket book
or something like that all right
willing to sustain or how much are you
willing to trade a lot so if you can
bring the cost down if you can produce a
lot more product for people at a lower
cost that would be a good thing from
utilitarian perspective now you know
when you lower costs that generally
means losing some other dimensions or
elements let's think about reliability
as well there's really nothing that
makes a product lose its value like
unreliability you know when I get a
phone I want that phone to do what it is
that's supposed to do without a lot of
which is you know I want the software
update stuff you can upgrade very
quickly and not going to screw things up
that lose my contacts for example I want
make a phone calls you know all sorts
advertisements about this I want to
actually get the other person on the
other end when I do my email on here I
want to go with emails actually going
out getting the email you know coffee
cup design you don't have to do it awful
lot of the coffee cup is a very
utilitarian coffee cup but it's got to
pour out right you know if it spills too
easily that would be unreliable design
we can think of this in terms of all
sorts of other things you know I have
some list of products product ranges
than we would often think about let's
think about clothing for Team
reliability in terms of clothing might
be you know if it's billed as being
waterproof it actually does keep the
water on you don't want to find that
sort of thing out when you're actually
put to the test cars or transportation
this is a big issue right you don't want
to end your car breaking down all the
time and need
years that also fits in the cost as well
living spaces you know you off the roof
to leak you want the plumbing fixtures
to work as they are supposed to you want
the air-conditioning another the heating
took two workers this bill food cooking
you know if you this wife some people go
go to chain restaurants because they
they have the sense that there is a kind
of reliability to them they know what
they're going to get and that's not
actually true necessarily really depends
on who's who's serving at who's managing
but there's a perception so reliability
is a plus for products right you can
make a product were liable for me until
appearing respected you're cutting out a
lot you're not necessarily giving
pleasure you're actually cutting up
caner and happiness that people feel
when the product fails from durability
this is closely related how long is your
product going to last I'll give you an
example for my own life we had some
rakes I've done a lot of ranking of
leaves and things like that in my life
the boys would be near or in the
countryside a few exceptions and so I
always had a yard that I had to take
care of my parents yard somebody else's
yard hey we can break that or built
really well and my grandfather had
bought them and I use those rates for at
least 25 years of my
my life until they finally started you
know breaking down when they broke down
it was only like individual bits teeth I
guess we call on the rink that we're
breaking go on and eventually got to the
point where I said I'd know going in
some new rates well most of the stuff
you can buy it out there in the store is
actually you know frankly speaking crap
it's not built to last and yeah so i
would start raking and you know this
plastic breaks that you can buy very
cheaply anywhere to go and the the rod
itself the handle it would span you know
i'm a big knock I put a lot of force
into it right and a step up well that's
not a useful product that's actually on
either cutting out clutter I actually
enjoyed raking leaves but I only enjoy
breaking leaves when it actually goes
right the product designers going to
minimize pain or Hamptons and you don't
notice these can all tie it together if
you may think so cheaply and you offered
us a lot of the market that we do and
all these big big box stores but the
product is basically just cheap crap
that people are mass-producing and a
really not designed for sustained use
then probably it's not a good idea for
me to look there you're going to me
there are certain break points you might
say where you know emphasizing cost you
know avoiding the on the happiness that
comes with paying more money is actually
cutting into these other values so you
have to think about that if you're
designing products from utilitarian
perspective cost is a factor but these
other things are important to go now
very often people think of utilitarian
as
in terms of products is just that you
know so I'm going to go get a coffin
you're the famous example you can pay a
lot of money for coffins or you some
pine box yeah they don't want to show
you my boxes because Pine boxes are very
cheap as far as like you know keeping a
dead body in the grave you know they're
all about the same for liability aren't
they and it's not going anywhere is it
so you know durability is not really
think you should either so you know just
go to the cheapest thing you could
possibly find that would be good utility
really thinking right there but other
other factors you know we can think
about this as well for coffee my coffee
in bulk don't get the fancy stuff that
requires a lot of marketing just you
know buy coffee that tastes good to you
and you're you're fine you know you're
getting a reliable experience by a ton
of it so you've got a lot of it up and
freeze it and you bite through the
cheaply we could go on and on and on
with examples like that yeah but is that
all there is to it you know doesn't ill
ethereal ISM mean giving up on beauty
design on Form we call the studies well
only a short-sighted Kennedy to
tourism we do that because yeah
utilitarianism is about pleasure isn't
done so it's not just cutting out
people's pain or providing tools that
help them get the job done you also want
things to look nice look I could hear
you know design he has to do with the
look of things but this is not an
attractive it wasn't even attracted when
the lettering it was the air i paid like
a couple bucks for it and it entitle me
to my coffee more cheaply that's why i
bought my otterbox that I have this is
designed for durability this is not
designed for books there are some you
know phone covers that are a lot more
pretty and you know might feel better in
the hand but this thing this is designed
to take a beer actually unfortunately
put it through the wringer but this is
what my military students used to like
back when i taught at Fayetteville State
University and for good reason because
if this is close too close to not
completing the close to a break so for
somebody like me is kind of closets it's
very handy yeah but doesn't look very
nice doesn't if you could design a
product that actually have these
features over here but also look nice
from utilitarian perspective that would
be the right thing to do the feel of
things is also very particularly when we
get to say tools you know or
transportation or clothing you know you
can make very cheap clothing that
doesn't fit well and it doesn't
that's good something doesn't look as
good it doesn't feel as good for the
person who's wearing cars &
transportation I have a very difficult
time finding cars that are good for me
in part because I'm 6 foot 3 yet have
gone torso so I sit up pretty high it's
hard to get good visibility it's also
hard to get black room in today's cars
not so hard in earlier cars interesting
but but it is hard in today's cars which
tend to be designed i think for people
who are on average about five foot eight
maybe if that so few things is important
living spaces the feel of living spaces
is incredibly not only look but how how
people flow how how it feels to your
going into them these things can be
difficult to quantify that is our way to
ground this tool should be designed so
that they actually put the hand well
sometimes you pay a bit more for a tool
that actually you know fits your body
well and it makes us it makes good sense
for utilitarian perspective because it
gives you pleasure to have that kind of
tool I hiding a lot of or happening
outdoors and I can tell you the
difference between a cheap shovel and
shovel that's well designed is in front
chainsaw chain saws can be put together
shadi wait just you know get the job
done more or less providing and run them
too much if you actually are the
professional you got a Bible high energy
to us because it's got to have the
durability but it fits your your body it
becomes a joy to use and that's about
that's my maximizing pleasure for people
isn't it the sound of things we might
even go on sale talk about the other
sense of smell taste all those are the
things and the performance itself how
does it how does it interface with you
so from utilitarian perspective op
Beauty does matter you know if if you
know getting a phone case that actually
had let's say you lump sums and let's
say you were in love with the painting
the screen and it had network which is
the screen on the back right so you can
look at the screen every half an hour or
so when you take out your phone if
you're counting them big phone user and
it gives you a little bit of pleasure
each time from utilitarian perspective
that would be a good product right not
of course to terrify your juice probably
a bad product good is that all there is
is that all we ever know and this really
has to do with you this part of the
great establishment need to minimize
pain or handles so you have to ask when
it comes to products and product design
about me call me supply chain this way i
have to have a lot of trouble for tlie
but other companies to as well are you
in order to produce these kinds of
things
in order to produce some of these kinds
of values particularly in terms of this
one right are you outsourcing human
misery are you inflicting pain
unhappiness in a variety of different
forms deprivation hager unsafe working
conditions that can lead to accidents
that can lead to abuses all sorts of
things that people don't not only don't
enjoy to find a grading humiliated are
you building that into the product it
remember from utilitarian perspective
everybody's pleasures and pains count so
if your product is being designed being
produced the Inkatha sent out let's say
being traded here and there and it's a
product that by the way it's designed is
going to require a lot of other people's
very well be dangerous sometimes
sometimes painful labour to go into it
that has to be factored in as it's part
of the equation so if you had two
different products and one of them was
slightly cheaper than the other but it
had a much higher cost in human misery
that should actually a much higher costs
overall and not just a dollar and you
probably should not prefer that product
if you're a good utilitarian you would
you would probably be concerned about
where your garage is coming from you
would probably also want to know
possible this is you one thing about
that if you could design a product so it
could be less easily misused by people
to Klaus elliptical pain or unhappiness
you would want to do that utilitarian
perspective so I mean you can think
about all of these there's lots of other
examples you can do to come up with but
think about all of these and how they
how they play out even though websites
and apps you know you want website
Graham to be reliable you want it to
look a certain way supply chain unless
you had much programs you know change
desks and probably in Russia possible
misused could be could be a real issue
in designing some sort of web site or
yeah you know if you're designing a
philosophy website probably the biggest
[ __ ] views that you might get out of it
would be students cutting corners using
your information incorporating into
papers and you know it's not a good
thing that's kind of a fairly small
utilitarian perspective but what if you
were designing a website that allowed
people to look up you know former
classmates we were kind of kind of
weak in security protocols are building
in to that end of the people and some
people were using this to look up their
spouses who they left them because they
used them and now they wanted to track
down their their spouse and abuse them
more well that would be a possible
misuse and if you had two different
websites one of which allows that sort
of thing one of which doesn't allow that
from utilitarian perspective the one
that allows it is a much more
proposition than the one that doesn't
love so there's a lot of different
factors that go into just thinking about
products we're not even yet after the
level of human decisions of choices and
all that's one of them you know how
should we design products that we
surround ourselves with external goods
in the traditional classification of
goods that's probably enough about that
the only other thing I want to talk
about is a good basic food would it make
sense from utilitarian perspective to
pay a little bit more for food that is
well plated tastes better looks better
is offered to you at a congenial
atmosphere that's probably an issue this
is an issue
this big who was actually involved in
the production or even some gather who's
picking your vegetables and fruits who
is killing me how is it getting how much
resources are being consumed to get back
from California or from Chile or
wherever they're getting stuff from to
your table for if you were a utilitarian
you would probably be concerned about
that so I think if you ready to latarian
you know you probably would be concerned
things like sustainability and your
labor practices things along those lines
so well off with that and I'm going to
shoot a number of these other videos
talking about other examples